welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show so one of the big pieces of news of
the day the NBA has now suspended the
regular season until further notice that
of course is not a grand shot given the
fact that Rudy Gobert the center for the
Utah Jazz was a fair apparently infected
with corona virus and was walking around
touching everything he could possibly
put his hands on and now we have another
member of the Utah Jazz who's been
infected the NHL is announcing it the
delay of its season the MLB is
announcing the suspension of spring
training which means the delay of its
season joining us on the line to discuss
all of this is clay travis clay is of
course the analyst on fox's support ones
college of pregame show he's also the
host of Fox Sports is nationally
syndicated out kick the coverage clay
good to talk to you how are you well you
know hanging in there it's it's really
obviously a really scary time for
everybody who's watching all of this
stuff obviously the the activities of
Rudy Gobert are really not responsible
for what happened in the NBA I think it
was basically inevitable that all of
these sports leagues were gonna have to
at the very least get rid of the crowds
for the moment and now that they are
canceling these games altogether now
what has been the impact on both the
players and the fans seismic unlike
anything we have ever seen before I
don't you know I know in sports and in
current events we have a tendency to
grab hyperbole and exaggerate current
events but I think without precedent for
certainly the vast majority of people's
lives this is unbelievable
and to have I think we said it right
Rudy Gobert accelerated what may have
well already happened but he took out
the medium ground which was we might
have played games with no crowds for a
month or so right if the players had
stayed healthy and that was going to be
sort of the compromise between you know
business as usual and an adjustment for
coronavirus and then when Gobert tested
positive we just skipped right past that
sort of interact them of the games
without without crowds and now I mean
look I I'm sort of stunned right I mean
I do a three-hour national sports talk
radio show every morning you know I got
from 6:00 to 9:00 a.m. Eastern to fill
every day and
tweeted I guess you know my little
league games are just ansel right now so
I guess I can come in and treat those
like Game seven of the World Series
every morning you know I even tweeted
make sure we all start watching a
television show together people who
usually spend their mornings with me but
I mean literally I mean I you know I
really don't know what to say I mean I
you know this we do a sports gambling
show every day on fs1 lock it in
you know I pulled up the sports gambling
app and there's literally nothing to bet
on yeah okay and you know runs on
coronavirus over/under zone yeah yeah I
mean literally it's unprecedented and
and so III think anybody to kind of
forecast exactly how long this situation
is going to go on is is well above my
paygrade certainly both you know as you
look at the scenarios that are occurring
globally I think the question is can the
United States be more like South Korea
than we are like Italy and and I think
that remains to be seen
yeah then obviously this is very scary
stuff some of the measures that have
been taken in in terms of the NBA Mark
Cuban was was asked last night in the
middle of the game about the suspension
of the season and Mark Cuban I thought
it was pretty great he actually
suggested that he was gonna come up with
some sort of measures to be taken they
would help out the hourly workers people
forget that there are economies that
don't just involve the players I mean
the players are gonna be fine they have
guaranteed salaries and some of these
sports at the very least you know
they're millionaires and in most of
these sports but a lot of the hourly
workers the people who are working the
concession stands the people who are
working the ticket booth now all those
people are basically on furlough have
there been any discussions internally at
any of these leagues about making sure
that all these people get sort of the
salaries that they are that they need in
order to get through this time yeah I'm
sure there's gonna be some discussions
about that and you know as well as I do
as a lawyer yearly for my lawyer head on
you could join me I mean the lawsuits
that are going to come out at this
corona virus outbreak or without
precedent but you know I mean you think
about it let's say I'm sure the NBA has
loss of season for instance insurance
with somebody out there and I don't know
what they would have been paying for
that every year probably whoever has
that insurance is like man we should be
charging a lot more than we did but you
know in the event the season doesn't
come back or they miss 15 or 20 games
what sort of compensation models exist
or not just
team's not just the players not just the
owners but as you just said everybody
who is employed inside of these arenas
what about the city that rely on these
arenas to be occupied and the concession
stands that are going to be sold as a
result what about all of the different
different television contracts let me
think about what what in the world I
mean I work on fs1 I work it's yes PN
obviously is out what are they going to
put on yeah I mean there's literally no
sports programming that they can put on
I guess they can put on you know like
classic games you know basically let you
know hey we're gonna go back to the you
know the Lakers versus the Celtics and
and instead of playing NBA real games
we're going to play old you know Michael
Jordan games things like that I
generally don't know because again to
circle back to what I said we're in a
situation which occurs very very rarely
there is literally no precedent in the
modern era for anything akin to this the
world sports I mean the last time we saw
something like this was actually the
middle of World War two when games were
being shut down and seasons were being
suspended we really have not seen
anything like this in in modern America
really in history so it pretty it is
pretty astonishing so clay this does
shed some new light on the the NBA's
willingness to do business and consider
how they were defending everything
china-related
like three months ago and saying a bad
word about China was considered very bad
if he said anything good about Hong Kong
and the NBA was very angry at you know
this certainly puts that in a different
light well Steve Kerr said that's a
complicated issue you know when he was
asked whether he supported democracy and
the First Amendment and on Hong Kong and
you know I mean it is it is wild I mean
I think what this represents more than
anything else is we all know this but
just how interconnected we are as a
world that decisions that are made in
China that seem very far away and
certainly for most of human history
would have not impacted people on this
side of the globe can not only impact
people they can do it instantaneously
and and so the hope this year that we
can marshal all the resources of the
world's brilliant people and we need
basically a Manhattan Project of to
fight this global global pandemic now I
do think that there is a you know an
element of hysteria that has
sort of taken over right you know and
and so I've been talking about that and
tweeting about it to try to because I do
think fear at this point in time becomes
as big of a danger almost as as the
pandemic itself right because if people
start to behave totally irrationally it
isn't helpful to any countries and and
it doesn't lead to any sort of solution
and I hope that sports by canceling here
is is going to lead to to a better
result than we might otherwise have had
but I again I think it's hard to
forecast like I said earlier I think the
question is which of the spectrums are
we going to head towards are we going to
be more like South Korea who appears to
have vanished this this coronavirus
thanks to a great effort and work on
their government's behalf and the people
who live there or are we gonna spiral
further into into a mess like it has
happened certainly in Italy and bunch of
other parts of Europe Clay Travis host
and Fox Sports it nationally syndicated
out kick to coverage good luck on phone
three hours dude I mean oh my god hours
a week of sports talk with no sports
stories and games to discuss it's gonna
be a hell of a challenge I mean I you're
just gonna have to do who's the who's
the greatest centerfielder of all time
for two hours a day I mean every day
we're just gonna have a great debate you
know like you have to you only could
pick one coach in the history of sports
to win a game who were you taking I will
do three hours on it probably one day
okay I appreciate the time good luck
stay safe out there dude hey appreciate
you'll have me on